uh i think we're done
you said we should come here
you are going to love it there are so
many kinds of wishes maybe that you have
never ate them before really let's go
and find out okay let's go let's go are
you sure about this yeah i trust you you
know
don't
you know so guys i've come to turkey i
was invited by susan
yeah oh sorry we don't i forgot i'm so
sorry
this okay
we still have corona right they still
have corona
yes as you can see we have a youtube
channel in turkey
since 11 years 11 years yes
so we started our english channel
maybe four years ago already yeah we
just got ali dawa
or to our studio we asked some hard
questions he got sweaty maybe you don't
want to say this
but yeah today we're here as you guys
know we're dining to jannah because we
are eating towards gender inshallah
what's the
this place is special for us because
it's very hard for us to find
a restaurant a fish restaurant without
alcohol okay
so this is very
special for the people especially who
are who are living in basha okay
we get here and we don't have any
alcohol in front of us
how do you find the menu so this is the
menu as you can see
you know what i like about menus when i
go to a restaurant but sometimes if i'm
going to a restaurant i haven't tried
before i like to see what my food will
look like so sometimes we'll have it but
there'll be no picture this restaurant
has a different serving method okay in
this restaurant what is popular is that
you get so many kinds of fishes
small into small pieces
they call that hot appetizer okay that's
interesting so what they do here guys is
they give you like little portion size
so instead of ordering for example i
want to try sea bass they don't they can
bring the sea bass if you want it but
what they do is they have special
methods where they have small sea buses
so you can order a bit of sea bass a bit
of swordfish a bit of salmon a bit of
king prawns what does he recommend let's
obviously there's tamari
maybe i'm connected you know evolution
maybe
[Laughter]
so we ordered 12 59 exactly okay i've
noticed when you're ordering your food
you're not ordering king prawns
you're not ordering is there is there a
reason we have allergy what's your
what's your reason yani
uh i'm hanifi and you are humbly ah so
our rules are different okay i can't eat
uh
colormates
calamari honey calamari yeah i can't eat
oh that's why you know okay the the
worst point is that i can't eat muscle
you can't eat muscle you kind of
calamari you can't eat king prawns yeah
your life is very difficult
my life changed when i was 20 years old
so
you know when i started to practice
islam but i sometimes
miss muscle you know muscle yeah like
like me
oh the other okay all right sorry you
like it
i tried it it's nothing
not special and i don't mind being a
honeybee for that guys if you enjoyed
the video you can check our new dining
to jannah channel inshallah for more
videos every single week where we review
all kinds of restaurants and cuisines
all over the world
this is a message saying this app has
been such a game changer to me i've
never been so consistent with my quran
reading before i knew about quran lead
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
this is how people's lives are changing
and you can get quranili absolutely free
no credit cards for seven day free trial
what are you waiting for download it now
brown sisters and build a habit with the
korani app right now you can find the
link for ios and android in the link
description below